i would not have imagined entering this
world in a 1950s sitcom like
into the mcu like it's the whole thing
is so trippy to me
and so excited it's really it's really
bananas
oh this is gonna be a gaff i want to ask
you how good of a secret keeper
you are huh i
i you know what i am learning to be a
fantastic super secret exactly turns out
i am
really turning out to be a fantastic
secret keeper yeah because you know when
you dive into the marvel universe
it's like you gotta like i don't know i
don't know what you saw in a way
but you gotta give it up you gotta zip
it up shut it up
never say a word no you do and i i mean
i remember i did
i definitely remember when mark uh sweet
ruffalo
didn't you get busted for like yeah and
i was like i do not want to pull a
ruffle
i am gonna i i'm gonna really zip it up
i mean even my like i don't even think
my you know no one
no one no one in my life i was gonna say
who in your life
is the one who would like needle you the
most about giving some secrets or some
spoilers or trying to get you to say
something
i have something for i have a couple of
friends that are
real deep comic book aficionados
that have really really really really
wanted
to know and um i
have had to run a real tight ship and
they because they come towards me with
that extra glass of wine
that's my kryptonite i'd be done and
right through that and that is a no well
fans are really you know fans are like
really trying to dig deep and figure out
what your mcu origins
are no i know
you're doing it like you know i this is
my
you know foray into the mcu world and
these fans are incredible and really
like
i mean passionate and have like
incredible
i mean are so passionate and so creative
and like
have so many i mean i've heard some of
the theories
and um i mean it is like
it's awesome i mean it's really
incredible what part of that whole
aesthetic
did you love the most because i think it
was like elizabeth's voice changed to
being very dumb
like how do you know this whole thing i
loved it yeah
i mean we yeah i know i mean you know
the aesthetic
i mean it's it's so beautiful and also
i just feel so glad that we are out of
that
um that i mean the
just because i mean on so many levels
for so many reasons
but like the
the constriction on a woman and why her
voice had to be raised like that
and like that's just like you know like
all of
all of it was like so i was uh um
um what would i say i loved about it
i mean i will say it was a sensible heel
that's the one thing i can say
honey a kitten heel yes we've gotten
taller and taller
and i don't know how or why but there
was something about a sensible heel that
i was like
okay now hear me out catherine because
as
evolved of a woman as i believe that i
am and
really have lived my life to try to be a
fully realized woman in every sense of
the word
i tell you when i was watching that i
kind of thought i would kick ass as a
50s housewife i love to cook i love to
entertain like i
might be pretty darn good at it how do
you think you would do
i would not do as well no i i
i like i'm still trying to find the joy
in in having to like in all of it
like in the in the and i have to uh
there are sometimes like you know where
it's like i just
look at that freaking
crap in the shower the grout and i'm
just like oh
god i just like please can't get that
toothbrush out and i got to do it but i
don't want to
and i never said find the joy some
people can be like
no meditate through it or what i'm just
like i
just can't do it but i got to
i'm not gonna i loved the um the the
women's magazine
in in episode one where they was talking
about the seduction move
stumble when you can catch you i know
i know i know do i have a move i don't
think i have
a move i think i'm just that clumsy and
goofy
that i don't i could never have like
that little koi
totally oh my god we were like that and
also like ps like those are for real
magazines like the whole thing is just
like
wow whoa
i love it do you wear it um because i do
feel like
it is a bit of a badge of honor though
to where
um you know being the first marvel
spin-off
series out of the gate i mean that is
that's
that is pretty damn cool it's so crisp
so awesome like i i'm still like
i i'd still yeah and in this and in this
show which is so different from anything
that they've done
like with this group of humans it's like
i mean tiana's amer so so incredible and
and and lizzie and paul and like and
this director and the writer i like
and these artisans who put this together
and i mean
the authenticity with every single genre
and i'm just so excited for you to see
where it goes like
i'm yeah i could not be i i'm so yeah
it's i could not be more worthy well i'm
a blurred i'm a black nerd so this is
right up my alley so i'm all ready for
this i'm all
in for this um i also want to know
though because you know we've been at
home
for what seems like seven years now but
honestly
and so we pretty much watched and binged
everything
and i think that i've watched bad moms
had moms too probably five times
so is there gonna be a three like what
are you guys gonna
do i have no idea what is happening
there i mean i know we would love
we would love it but i have no i don't
have no idea
what is happening there but it would be
it would be fun i had heard rumors of
about a bad grandma's but
i hope which i i think would be really
fun too because i was gonna say
i think that would be amazing would you
be up for returning i mean would you
like to oh my god yeah i'd love to and i
love those
women so much and they would so deserve
it and they would
freaking take it and run and i think it
would be so fun
well i'm just gonna end with when i was
talking to elizabeth olson
um she gushed about you a bit about
how you made this experience so amazing
so
i'll just ask you to return the favor
have a little sister spirit
and just talk about working with her and
and that experience i
i mean that makes me want to cry i
love that human she has such integrity
and she's such an incredible incredible
actor and she just
is is just an honest decent
good human being um and we just
made each other laugh and we just you
know we went through a lot in the course
of this
you know this a lot happened in this lab
as we all know and like
she just is such a a decent decent human
being and um
yeah i hold her very very very dear to
[Music]
me